et une semaine après les attentats une
semaine plusieurs semaines après les
attentats de paris oscille de
recrutement de l'armée de terre connaît
un afflux inédit de visiteurs plus de
1400 internautes connectés chaque jour
sur s'engager point fr contre 200 à 300
en moyenne ces derniers mois a précisé
le bureau du recrutement pour en parler
avec nous en direct par téléphone le
colonel bruno mais une brune aubert en
charge du commandement du regroupement
de recrutement et de sélection d'île de
france et d'outre-mer bonsoir alors on
sera à vous et merci de répondre à notre
question cette augmentation justement de
volontaires à skrela constaté également
dans les yvelines
donc normalement oui
la tourmente à sion pas réglé puisque
mois en novembre
loto nous avons trois fois plus de
contacts dans le document alors qu'ils
sont ceux qui souhaitent justement
intégrer l'armée c'est évidement les
attentats de paris du 13 novembre
dernier et est ce que vous avez
justement besoin de ces candidatures
oui ils ont besoin de ces candidatures
puis je suis comme comme vous l'avez les
privant de la république a décidé
d'augmenter de 11000 m la force
terrestre ici des michettes effet jeunes
qui viennent dans tout ça un point
commun fiction tous nos vins de france
et qui ont entre 17 ans et dont trente
ans et qui sont motivés pour sa vers
leur pays et en particulier fut qui met
en avant depuis les attentats du 13
novembre cette volonté de se mettre en
face de l'autre de ce roman qui
est justement voilà il atteint juste
après l'émotion c'est des créateurs
comme que vous retenez dont vous avez
besoin
je vienne qui ce cas n'a pas la portion
centre de recrutement
ils viennent tous avec leurs motivations
et que tous les dix mètres en avance
on monte des cerveaux notre pays les
ensuite il rentre dans mon processus de
sélection qui se déroule en quatre
étapes première étape de contacter une
étape ensuite d'évaluation de
leur qualité et puis enfin une étape
d'orientation où on va faire mûrir
neurones rejouer leur volonté de rentrer
à mon père en l'art en réalité on a
souvent correspondre avec mes petits
plombs notre arme nucléaire très bien
merci beaucoup à bruno baer pour à ces
précisions nous suivrons bien sûr allez
vous cette actualité